y las máquinas emitían pitidos inexplicablemente
mientras un reloj de pared señalaba que el día se convertía en noche.
Ese reloj estaba encima de una puerta
en línea directa a la vista donde mi esposa estaba recostada
mientras sus contracciones aumentaban hora tras hora.
Ahora bien, yo nunca di a luz...
(Risas)
pero ella me aseguró que lo último que una mujer que da a luz querría
era ver pasar los segundos.
(Risas)
Como arquitecto de profesión, siempre me fascinó
ver a las personas experimentar el diseño en el mundo a su alrededor.
Creo que el diseño funciona como la banda sonora
que no nos damos cuenta que se está reproduciendo.
Nos envía mensajes subconscientes acerca de cómo sentirnos
y qué esperar.
Esa habitación en la que estábamos parecía completamente desconectada
del momento que estábamos viviendo...
recibiendo a un ser humano,
a nuestra hija en este mundo.
En un momento, una enfermera, de la nada,
nos miró y dijo:
"Siempre me digo a mí misma
'Ojalá hubiera sido arquitecta,
porque hubiera podido diseñar mejores habitaciones como estas'".
Le dije:
"Un arquitecto diseñó esta habitación".
(Risas)
A pesar de la inmensa alegría por el nacimiento de nuestra hija,
los mensajes de esa habitación permanecen con ella y conmigo hasta hoy.
Esos mensajes son:
"No estás en tu hogar,
estás en un lugar extraño".
"No tienes el control de nada.
Ni siquiera de la iluminación".
"Tu comodidad, simplemente, es secundaria".
En el mejor de los casos,
una habitación de hospital como esta
puede ser descrita o desestimada como aburrida.
En el peor de los casos, es indigna.
Y lo utilizo para señalar que ninguno de nosotros,
en ningún lugar del mundo,
somos inmunes al mal diseño.
Estudié arquitectura porque creía
que consistía en crear espacios para que las personas vivan mejor su vida.
Sin embargo, encontré una profesión en gran parte desconectada
de las personas que reciben el impacto directo de su trabajo.
Creo que esto se debe a que la arquitectura
sigue siendo una profesión blanca, masculina y elitista...
aparentemente desentendida
de algunas de las grandes necesidades en el mundo
o incluso de las simples necesidades de una madre embarazada.
Los estudiantes se preparan en la universidad
con proyectos puramente teóricos,
y rara vez interactúan con personas de verdad o con comunidades reales.
Los graduados son encauzados a través de un camino largo,
angosto y despiadado hacia la licencia.
Mientras tanto, la profesión retiene a unos pocos seleccionados
a través de incesantes programas de reconocimiento
enfocados casi exclusivamente en la estética de los edificios,
antes que en el impacto social o en la contribución de los mismos.
Solo ayuda a reforzar una visión distorsionada
de la responsabilidad profesional y el éxito
y sin embargo este no es motivo por el que muchos jóvenes optimistas
se meten en la arquitectura.
No es por lo que yo lo hice.
En ese entonces creía, aunque no tenía un lenguaje para ello,
y ahora lo sé, que el diseño tiene una capacidad única para dignificar.
Puede hacer que las personas se sientan apreciadas,
respetadas,
reconocidas y visibilizadas.
Ahora quisiera que piensen en algunos de los lugares que habitan.
Y quiero que piensen en cómo los hicieron sentirse.
Ahora bien, hay lugares que nos hacen sentir tristes,
enfermos,
o aburridos.
Tal vez sean los lugares donde trabajan
o donde se curan
o incluso donde viven.
Y me pregunto, ¿cómo podrían estos lugares diseñarse mejor teniendo a Uds. en mente?
Es una pregunta muy sencilla
y a veces puede, de alguna manera, ser muy difícil de responder.
Porque estamos condicionados a sentirnos como si no tuviéramos mucho poder
sobre los espacios y lugares donde vivimos, trabajamos y jugamos.
Y en muchos casos no lo tenemos.
Pero deberíamos.
Bien, aquí va una pregunta quizá tonta para cualquier mujer que está mirando:
¿Alguna vez estuvieron
en una fila para ir al baño desproporcionadamente larga?
(Risas)
Alguna vez pensaron: "¿Cuál es el problema de esto?"
Bueno, qué tal si la verdadera pregunta fuera:
"¿Cuál es el problema con los hombres que diseñaron estos baños?"
(Aplausos)
Puede parecer algo insignificante,
pero es representativo de un problema más grave.
El mundo contemporáneo fue literalmente construido por hombres
que rara vez se han tomado el tiempo para entender
cómo otras personas, a diferencia de ellos,
experimentan sus diseños.
Una fila larga para ir al baño puede parecer una humillación menor.
Pero lo opuesto también puede ser cierto.
Un diseño detallista puede hacer que las personas se sientan respetadas
y visibilizadas.
He llegado a pensar que la dignidad es al diseño
lo que la justicia a la ley
y la salud a la medicina.
En términos más simples,
se trata de hacer que los espacios que habitamos reflejen nuestro valor.
En los últimos dos años
pude entrevistar a más de 100 personas de diferentes clases sociales
sobre sus experiencias con el diseño.
Quería poner a prueba mi corazonada
de que la dignidad y el diseño están estrechamente relacionadas.
Escuché a Gregory,
un residente de esta comunidad de cabañas
diseñadas específicamente
para las 50 personas más afectadas por la falta de vivienda en Dallas.
Gregory estuvo viviendo en la calle,
a la deriva de pueblo en pueblo por más de 30 años.
Una gran coalición
de agencias de servicios sociales,
financiadores y diseñadores,
crearon este lugar.
Cada cabaña de 37 metros cuadrados está diseñada a la perfección
como un hogar permanente.
Ahora Gregory tiene una llave
para una puerta
a su propia casa.
Él describe la sensación de seguridad que esto le brinda.
Algo que no tuvo durante tres décadas.
Cuando llegó con poco más que la ropa que tenía puesta,
encontró todo:
desde una tostadora, olla de cocción lenta y cocina
hasta un cepillo de dientes y pasta dentífrica lo esperaban.
Él lo describe simplemente
como el paraíso.
Al otro lado del mundo,
escuché a Antoinette,
directora de este centro de capacitación y comunidad
para mujeres en la zona rural de Ruanda.
Cientos de mujeres vienen a diario a este lugar
para aprender nuevas habilidades,
estar en una comunidad,
y seguir reconstruyendo sus vidas
luego de la guerra civil del país.
Estas mujeres literalmente colocaron
los 500 000 ladrillos
que conforman los 17 pabellones de aulas como esta.
Antoinette me dijo:
"Todos están muy orgullosos de esto".
Y luego, de vuelta en Estados Unidos
escuché a Monika,
directora de un centro de salud
que asiste principalmente a personas sin seguro en Arkansas.
A Monika le encanta decirme que los médicos,
que son voluntarios en el centro de salud
habitualmente le dicen
que nunca habían trabajado en un lugar tan hermoso y lleno de luz.
Monika cree
que incluso las personas pobres
merecen asistencia médica de calidad.
Además,
ella cree que merecen recibir ese cuidado
en un ambiente digno.
Personas como ellos son embajadores invaluables para el diseño
y sin embargo están rotundamente ausentes del discurso arquitectónico.
De manera similar, las personas que más pueden beneficiarse del buen diseño
por lo general son las que menos acceso tienen a él.
Tu primo, un veterano sin techo;
tu abuela o abuelo
que vive en una casa con una cocina que ya no es accesible;
tu hermana confinada a una silla de ruedas
en un área suburbana planificada sin aceras.
Si el buen diseño es solamente para unos pocos privilegiados,
¿de qué nos sirve?
Es hora de que los diseñadores cambien esto
dedicando sus prácticas al bien común
en el modelo de firmas
como Orkidstudio,
Studio Gang,
y MASS Design Group.
Sus clientes
son chicos huérfanos en Kenia,
niños de acogida en Chicago
y mujeres embarazadas en Malawi.
Sus prácticas están argumentadas en la creencia
de que todos merecen un buen diseño.
Dedicar más prácticas al bien común
no solo creará más diseño digno,
sino que también dignificará la práctica del diseño.
No solo variará la base de clientes del diseño,
sino que también creará nuevas y diversas formas de diseño
para el mundo.
Bien, para lograr esto,
mis amigos de arquitectura y diseño, en especial mis colegas blancos,
tenemos que diversificar simultánea y considerablemente nuestros rangos.
Si queremos que el público crea que el diseño es para ellos
y para todos.
Hoy, apenas el 15 %
de los arquitectos certificados en Estados Unidos son mujeres.
Y un porcentaje mucho menor son personas de color.
Otras profesiones, como abogacía o medicina
han dado pasos gigantes en estas áreas cruciales.
¿Cómo podría nuestro entorno artificial compartido
-- nuestras casas, hospitales, colegios y espacios públicos --
modelarse de manera diferente
si las mujeres y personas de color
estuvieran detrás de la mitad de los proyectos conocidos?
No pregunto si es así o no,
sino hasta qué punto
nuestros edificios, nuestros paisajes,
nuestras ciudades y comunidades rurales
son menos bellas, menos funcionales,
menos equitativas y menos dignificantes
porque es menos probable que las mujeres y las personas de color las creen.
Como señaló Winston Churchill en 1943
cuando pidió la reconstrucción
de las cámaras parlamentarias de Londres dañadas por la guerra:
"Nosotros moldeamos nuestros edificios, y luego, ellos nos moldean a nosotros".
La buena noticia es que podemos cambiar la manera de construir
y para quién construimos.
Ya sea para un trabajador de la salud en la zona rural de Ruanda,
o para una madre embarazada y un padre nervioso en Estados Unidos.
Podemos lograr esto volviendo a conectar a la arquitectura
con la salud, la seguridad y el bienestar del público.
Esto pagará dividendos.
Porque una vez que vemos lo que puede lograr el diseño,
no podemos dejar de verlo.
Y una vez que experimentamos la dignidad,
no podemos conformarnos con menos.
Ambas cosas se vuelven parte de nuestras posibilidades.
Una de mis compañeras de conversación preferidas es mi abuela de 90 años.
Audrey Gorwitz, de Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
Luego de una de nuestras conversaciones sobre diseño,
me escribió una carta.
Me dijo: "Querido Johnny:
El otro día pensaba, mientras esperaba en el consultorio médico,
qué deprimente es,
desde el color de la pared hasta la alfombra del piso.
(Risas)
Ahora tendré que llamar para ver
quién es el responsable de la monotonía en ese lugar".
(Risas)
En la misma carta, fíjense, dijo:
"Llamé y me comuniqué con el hombre a cargo,
y dijo que agradecía que alguien lo llamara.
El consultorio de mi médico ahora está en una lista para una mejora".
(Risas)
La firmó diciendo:
"Siempre es bueno expresar nuestras opiniones
si se hace de la manera correcta".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Amo a mi abuela.
(Risas)
Como mi abuela Audrey,
Uds. merecen buen diseño.
Porque los espacios bien diseñados
no reflejan solo nuestros gustos ni son una cuestión meramente estética.
Literalmente moldean nuestras ideas sobre quiénes somos en el mundo
y qué merecemos.
Esa es la esencia de la dignidad.
Representan una oportunidad y una responsabilidad de diseño
para siempre
y para todos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)